you've got three charts for us today the
first one is uh bitcoin and ethereum uh
and we're gonna pull it up here uh what
are you looking at when you see the the
bitcoin ethereum uh kind of charts
overlaid with each other yeah so uh
those two charts are what we call our
volatility adjusted momentum signal on
the top panel and the bottom panels are
probable range analysis so without being
too technically jargony but
what one thing that so the the the chart
on the bottom the bottom panel is where
we show the ranges
those ranges are quantitatively linked
to the volatility just a momentum signal
so if something's bullish there's more
skewed to the upside in the range if
something's bearish they're more there's
more excuse to the downside in the range
when some when an asset tends to sort of
hug the lower boundary or the upper
boundary of its probable range it's
usually a leading indicator nine times
out of ten that hey look i want to
transition to a more bullish or bearish
state and so right now bitcoin and
ethereum have been bearish for a while
as you might imagine um is denoted by
the red shading at the upper panel
but they've been hugging their probable
ranges pretty consistently for the last
week or so and that typically is like
hey look i'm sick of being bearish i
want to break out and when it breaks out
the rain shifts and changes and so i'm
watching that like a hawk because you
know that kind of leads me to the second
chart uh which is where i show uh net
liquidity so the net liquidity is is the
fed's balance sheet minus the treasury
general account balance um that's sort
of a more accurate depiction of how much
liquidity is being pumped into or
removed from asset markets at any given
time by the monetary and fiscal
authorities and what you see is that you
know you pull that chart back as far as
it goes it's a you know 0.9 something
correlation to the s p well every once
in a while it deviates either you know s
p goes meaningfully higher than it or
meaningfully lower than it the last time
we had a meaningfully lower deviation
was in september of 2021 and you know we
had that massive melt up in october 2021
which by the way we nailed um that
massive melt up was a function of look
we we
we deviated too much the monetary
conditions the liquidity conditions
didn't change well they haven't changed
much since early 2022 but we've had this
massive deviation in s p terms and risk
asset terms away from the net liquidity
line and so
the key takeaway was that okay now we're
on the other side of opex now we got
more color and clarity on the feds
tightening path we're still waiting to
get more info on quantitative tightening
we're probably going to get that
in the fed's early may meeting but for
now it seems like the coast is somewhat
clear unless we get a meaningfully
adverse shock from a geopolitical risk
perspective now
again i'll say this every week so i'm
blue in the face i have no idea what
we're going to get from a geopolitical
risk perspective no one does i'm not
even sure putin does it's a it's a rapid
fire game of chess right now
so in the context of not knowing what's
going to happen there we're saying look
the market could gravitate back towards
that blue line the red line in that
chart the market can gravitate back
towards that blue line and you kind of
look at it on um you know just on like a
correlation basis it's somewhere around
like 4 700 on the s p
in terms of where you could get up to
before anything else changes and that to
me is that's a that's a that's a if that
happened you know again there's a kind
of a one or two month window here where
that could happen before growth starts
to pick up to the downside and if that
does happen obviously you're probably
going to see bitcoin and ethereum do
some positive things when you start to
look at uh inflation as a driver i know
you've got the europe uh inflation
charts here but uh we're obviously
seeing this all across the world is that
a huge
tailwind or driver of this or do you
think that that's more of a
narrative on twitter or in the media but
these assets aren't really trading in
any correlation or impact by inflation
no so the so
one thing that's happened with with
crypto and this is something i said back
in october 2020 i think i was tweeting
at you and i say look the more
institutional uh firms adopt
cryptocurrency and digital assets in
general the more correlated it's going
to become to s p and nasdaq because you
know they have you know sort of fall all
targeting you know risk budgets and
things of that nature and so you know
it's all going to start to become one
kind of big trade and that's exactly
what happened and and so you know the
sort of inflation hedge aspect of the
crypto digital asset space sort of got
lost or got buried underneath the no
wait this is as far out on the risk
curve risk spectrum as you can possibly
be in terms of the the realized
volatility of the asset and so that
really in my opinion that institutional
adoption and obviously the institutional
puking of these types of assets um
really weighed on that so you know i
don't believe that it's lost its
inflation um you know hedge uh kind of
you know
inflation edge you know um ability it's
just that the risk you know kind of the
the widening of versus premia in this
most recent kind of you know two to
three months really you know so going
back to november um has been kind of
overwhelming factor but it just in terms
of explaining that chart so that i sent
that chart because the topic du jour
this week for sure is kind of this
meltdown in the bond market you know i
want to say it's it's like the worst
first quarter on record in the bond
market i mean as far back as we've got
the data which is you know to like 1970
something um so i'm sure there's been
worse quarters you know historically but
as far back as we have that bloomberg
index and so you know one thing that's
really been roiling the bond market and
keeping me up at night because i'm long
bonds
like an [ __ ] um
uh is the fact that you know this
european inflation dynamic is really
it's been it's been a big surprise like
we all know the u.s inflation dynamic
has been a big surprise to the upside
that's the blue line in the upper panel
that's the city's u.s inflation surprise
index which measures kind of like how
surprised are economists by inflation at
any given time so the higher the number
the more surprised economists are in
terms of their estimates well the blue
line is obviously he's been trending
kind of right around its all-time high
for the past you know kind of really
nine months um but the red line i mean
it looks like a you know for lack of a
better phrase looks like viagra you know
like europe's inflation surprise
momentum and the the kind of shock to
their the positive shock to inflation in
europe has been on the orders of
magnitude as a positive shock to
inflation in us and i think about
inflation u.s inflation it's all we talk
about you're going to leave here you're
going to complain about inflation you're
going to talk about inflation i'm going
to talk about inflation that's all
anyone talks about these days now
multiply that times three and that's
where europe is right now um and so that
that big shock to inflation really
catalyzed the massive repricing
in the european sovereign debt market
that started in early january and it
continues and and it's probably going to
continue until you know sort of a those
dynamics get under control i.e inflation
peaks in europe our model has that
occurring in the second quarter but more
importantly you know that repricing in
the european sovereign debt curve is
probably still hostage to
you know the fiscal response to um to
all this inflation pressure because
europe they're kind of talking about you
know maybe um cutting uh gas taxes
issuing checks to households um to sort
of help help offset prices which i think
is a stupid i mean dear god that's the
dumbest idea i've ever heard of my
entire life let's increase demand to
help fight inflation
i mean but they'll try and these people
these people we've seen enough from
these ridiculous economists you know
over the time so they have they have no
choice hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time